[Applause]
[Music]
how's it going bros
my name is sadly no edgar cam this week
i know but i do have a new microphone it
sounds like
pretty from here but if i go really
close
it sounds really good and like i'm
running a podcast or something
but it also looks extremely homosexual
which i'm of course okay with i'm not
tempted
i'm not attempted at all why who made
the microphones like this huh
explain this all right well we don't
have edgar cam but we do
have g fuel cam yeah
and we also have microphone cam yeah
and we have cam of display in the
background cam
yeah let's go all right
roll the interest side leave your memes
on the reddit 19
i'm actually really excited for this
week's lawyer because i haven't been
cheating
sometimes yes sometimes yes i cheat all
right
i'm sorry this week no people seeing a
meme with an
italian reference inhales might say
check yo what's up
oh wait she's gonna think no don't check
your whatsapp
anyway uh she explained this to me later
peepee
means oh god i forgot what do you mean
let me check
my dad what did the pp stand for
it stands for private property and i
didn't hey check your whatsapp
i'm joking don't check your whatsapp
damn all right i i can't do this anymore
i can't do this all right side
double dog cam maya and edgar cam
i don't even need to wear the headphones
anymore i have a new microphone hey maya
say something to the microphone
she loves it she's born to be a
podcaster oh my god you guys are
adorable
how do i not block you
all right you guys are so cute look at
you
why does microphones exist huh this is
not that bad actually
all right let's go with this this is
adorable
all right let's keep going uh very
strong can't wait to see what fan are
people gonna draw out of this
since people said he hated my other
animation animation
i made this one to regain my honor
alright got a lot of
boats all right got the headphones the
50mm awards that i don't have anymore
i used to have that audio interface
that's funny i hate this
i didn't hate it come on i don't
like this one i don't i don't like it
look at this
oh is there no audio
[Laughter]
that's sick well done your honor has
been restored
why are you guys so chill they're all so
annoying huh i think they've just been
fed that's literally why
but you you feed the pugs and you make
them poop they're like all right i sleep
now
mom can we have a mangoes no there's
some mongoose at home
among us at home jubilee it's funny
cause it's true right edgar
yeah but where's monsieur cam
we want a marcia cam all right
side add my chia can oh look she want to
lick it lick his ears
i should stop you give up
you can lick later you gotta do in your
eyes
i don't drug my pugs i swear oh [ __ ]
yeah
yeah yes i've sent me this don't go to
this website because it's not mine
and do for the love of god do not buy
anything from it because you'll
most likely get scammed my only merch
website
is represent.com pewdiepie or
pewdiepie.com
saw him then felix watch out orange
kinda says
damn we foretold the prophecy someone
dug up an old meme
for a new meme and i appreciate that
well done
oh look she's doing the lick thing
that's kind of gross my eye honestly you
just dispose yourself from being
disgusting
because she does not give a [ __ ] wi-fi
drops down by one bar youtube video
quality
look at guys they're making fun of you
look
i don't know why i thought this cam
thing was a good idea
hey yo side add ac remote cam
yeah hey yo side add what i'm reading
cam
yeah i feel like it needs more cans uh
felix everything i said was a joke
me who sacrificed my wife and three kids
to floor game
you sacrifice your wife and three kids
well done you're free
you're welcome uh no liberta i will save
you la brita knowing the creeper is
scared of cats
okay wait what really oh legend
oh okay that's good cats are actually
useful
holy [ __ ] oh labrita did their job oh my
god
you believe this that's crazy can't
believe it
imposter and pasta
i'll send that one to marzia see what
she thinks did she just triple dot me
did you just tripled up me oh yeah
triple dot dish
uh hey pewds i saw your among us video
and wanted to tell you
about a little trick you can tell the
imposter apart by looking at their eyes
because there's a little different
wait what oh
that's hilarious good job i didn't even
believe it to be honest i freaking hate
it
oh did i say
i'm sorry why was i so harsh on
it well he did you know what it worked
because now legend
put out about much better one so you
gotta respect it harsh criticism
perhaps but it led to well result and
more peepee
right i forgot here big peepee a light
to a big peepee
good job good job mate are you getting
tired of me maya what's happening
i don't care uh when you start with
sneaking a chair into rewind and then
get invited to his wedding and finally
play the game with him
parkour i don't like how everyone's like
making it seem like it's a privilege to
be friends with me or something
oh my god you got to play with yo
i got to play with jaden animations okay
it was cool she never became imposter
so i can always surprise okay that's
pretty good
i wouldn't say i hate it i wouldn't say
i love it either
medium-sized pee-pee i'm willing to
admit it edgar's literally like
falling into mush what are you having
look at him what is it again teacher
name a type of lasagna
me cheese lasagna then why did you write
peach lasagna
my brain that's the only lasagna i know
simply for better
oh nice guy hey guy you're a meme
template shipping formats yeah
i get your mean template wake up
come on that is so cute parents when
their
teenage son mentions a girl's name
parents when their teenage daughter
mentions a boy's name that is so are you
licking his ears again stop doing that
that's really nasty
i go you can tell her to stop if you
want
edgar stop being a simp and tell her to
sub
hey guys it's no september i thought i
told you
geez everyone
yeah the among the fall guys trend fell
off real fast
what come what is this meme i've never
seen it what comes after g
me h then why did you write
i understand i understand the meme now
all right i'm down with the kids
i get it mom we have visit there's me
stop licking my god
don't worry i'll protect you oh my god
what is it are you bothered by me now
kids the end crystal you place cannot be
picked up
are you serious i spent hours are you
serious
it looked like you placed them with the
idea that you can get them back yes
this is not the case if you try to mine
them they will explode
they have a huge blast radius and we'll
count that guys we have to save sven
right now
i'm launching minecraft let's save him
oh i'm sorry oh you don't like sven
what's your pr they're down for main
commands
no uh since you're all you're here
looking all cute and stuff let me show
you
the reason why you will never be the
perfect dog because the perfect dog
already exists
i want to introduce you yeah
there he is see that that's a real dog
you guys not even half as cute all right
i'm kidding i'm kidding hey sven say hi
to them
they're looking yeah you like them
that's
so weird all right i'll see you in the
bits man son
look at what are you doing man he's like
can i look closer
all right well thanks for letting me
know that's great yeah
so among us apparently it's a
two-year-old game it's not crazy
and it got so popular out of nowhere
i don't know who made it popular i know
toast is like the guy that's
famous for being good at it but i don't
know like how he got so big
it's awesome i love that say what you
want about uh
this year but at least it's been good
for gaming dude uh i'll pour in gang
no it took me a second
yeah oh it's funny
uh four months in real life is the
equivalent of 24 years in minecraft
which means sven sat there for 24 years
waiting
what all right i'm keeping my minecraft
on at all times
if that's the case that's not that's way
too much wait pasta again e
all right i know it's no simp september
but uh this is [ __ ]
marta cooks the best pasta and i'm lucky
every day she cooks with food okay i
love pasta is it great it's great
maybe a little high on the carbs but
this is that this me makes no sense
well i'm actually going to give you
small pee pee using a screenshot
making a fan art instead but this is not
fan art
you just took the photo and put a filter
on it you guys
uploaded this are you serious i hate it
[Laughter]
aren't we gonna kill it
sven sven's boyfriend deep alabama
good meme big beefy
oh did you hear that fart that was
massive
oh that was the biggest part
oh get out of here oh
oh i'm dying oh my god yeah you better
be ashamed
oh god that's disgusting okay you would
never pull that on me
i found pewdiepie's star next to
us at a random shop in abu dhabi
nice that's a big peepee thank you india
very cool in abu dhabi is in india right
oh no thank you united arab emirates
very cool just a reminder that this
picture exists also today is joji's
birthday so i just want to
want people to wish him uh two days ago
well i'm excited for his new album
nectar coming out
in like a couple days epic
[Laughter]
well you guys beat me to it huh well
done i'm proud of you
we don't have i can what the [ __ ] my ass
fart is still lingering
that was absolutely disgusting it didn't
even sound like a part but i could feel
her stomach
vibrate it was nasty i gave my 40
40 million subscriber 40 cars the guy
who subbed to mr b
since day one right i was thinking about
this
you're incentivized highly to not be
subscribed to mr beast
and not be a longtime supporter what
that's so cool though
the four horsemen the blub ah
we don't have a maya version yet yeah my
my sleeping on the floor in shame
disgusting that was nasty you're never
gonna get maya cam again
jesus
what the [ __ ] were you doing oh no way
they animated it all right all right so
this is uh
this is one of my first imposters where
i went into the vent
after i murdered someone
okay i'm the viking guy i didn't i don't
know what i do
what the f were you doing i saw you
jumping into the [ __ ] bed
you're the one that jumped in the van oh
great speed he freaking killed point ass
out
i just found dylan standing right over
uh
my body wait wait i was trying to help
him
[Laughter]
did you do you know how to report bodies
yes you were standing on a body you
didn't
i was asking if she was okay
that was so funny i love among us i'm so
glad that
video came out i mean there's game come
on pewds you're holding martial wrong
you could damage her
no i know everyone called me out for
simping i'm clearly not simply
in this i think if anything this shows
for
this is definite proof right edgar this
is definite proof that i'm not a simp
thank you and that i'm still lashing
through september
what is this cake i made with my mom for
my birthday much but it's honest work
that's pretty cool good job uh
i i don't like the font i'm gonna be
real with you i i really don't like the
fun
i do like the rainy thing it could be
nice if there was some splash of the
rain
you know you're kind of missing that
right technically it should hit here
here maybe it could be nice with some
reflective puddles so yeah try again
i don't hate it a billion likes and i
will play minecraft this week's everyone
know in the video 100 billion likes but
one feels to play minecraft again
why must you hurt us in this way hey i
did play minecraft
i did and i [ __ ] up before marriage
480p 720p after marriage
yeah you dragged them down to your own
level
yeah that's how it's done right edgar
why do you look so
amazed by the scream what do you he
really likes the memes huh
he's really stuck on something isn't he
i cannot for the love of god remind
remember this tweet
but i have not seen any tweet more times
in this tweet
the alleged tweet is said to have been
posted on the eighth day of february
2017.
looking at way back machine snapshots of
pewdiepie's twitter timeline from the
12th of february 2017 we can see that
the alleged tweet does not exist
now one might argue that the tweet might
have been deleted soon after it was
posted and therefore was not archived in
the wayback machine snapshots well
digging further through the historical
snapshots we can establish that
pewdiepie only started using this duck
avatar in april of 2018 which is the
same avatar visible in the screenshot
this implies that the tweet must have
not been deleted until at least april of
2018 and should have been visible in the
snapshot from the 12th of february 2017
if it were real
whatever your fantasies may be it is
time for you to accept this reality and
to stop reposting this fake screenshot
so true i knew i wasn't crazy i knew i
never tweeted that i don't remember it
you [ __ ] gaslit me into making a
porno what the hell is it
it's not happening big peepee well done
finally
your honor i'm free i knew i did oh
wait what my wife's favorite pastime
it's distracting me while i'm cleaning i
don't really mind though
has been the best days of my life every
day with am i reading this manga the
wrong way let me finish cleaning
okay every table matching has been a big
deal
oh whoa the quality of this god damn oh
that's amazing look at that guy look at
that you're so cute oh god i cannot get
over how disgusting her fart was
sorry again all right you go on the
floor now uh
the tambourine is available right now if
you're a tier three
member that's right we're rewarding
people
that are on yeah tear free
just letting you know since everyone's
asking for it i don't know i didn't make
this decision
damn collecting dust
it is what it is i don't know what the
plans are i'm not even following i'm too
busy i can't be bothered
[Music]
okay that's smooth
okay i like it yes and it's got the
music included
[Applause]
i love it well done
i think it should be a little slower
because like you have this low-fi
music right it's a bit too intense
almost it needs to be
you know chill slow it down a bit then
then you'll get my big peepee
i'm sorry i didn't realize how that was
going to sound like
doing a collab with pewdiepie i have
lost so much respect for you dbrand hold
on we'll get you a spotlight
yes every [ __ ] time no one cares
i'm so glad there's a brand that have
some balls every guy just
enjoying his sleep pewds about to record
the video
[Laughter]
good meme good meme right there and the
guy come it's time to shoot the video
yes my lord
uh hey some funny memes here
i'll give the p i'll give the peepees
i'll give the peepee to you it's all
good all right what do we got here
another three
that's become a meme now i don't know
why okay i like it a lot
yeah i might actually use that simple
apparently i need 500
pewds around 19 year olds it's right
oh i'm still thinking about the fart
guys it's in the back of my head it was
so
nasty damn why do people not use those
that's decor
do you want to explode no i do not what
the [ __ ]
edgar after seeing all the memes from
you and we made you put them the [ __ ]
they doing over there
oh they're so cute they're sleeping next
to each other
ah there they are i found you
what even are my videos they are so
weird i like the minimal
it just feels a bit too basic plus the
pendulum thing oh okay you had another
thing there
it doesn't make sense then i suppose the
first dog to get their own camera must
have been like
yeah he's he's kind of cute sometimes
i do find our feelings in the pink
sweater because why not hey
the details about it took ages yeah
because i never wore that sweater what
the hell
damn damn all right
soaker drawers soccer draws well well
done very nice oh my god more edgar
memes
when i'm trying to see he looks like an
old sage
he looks so old he's not even that old
we got edgar yarning when the world
needed him most
oh i think maya my young is upstairs are
you winning son
no dad you call me ugly luau you cry
more you little [ __ ]
oh my god
yeah okay sure that's funny i'm still
thinking about the part it's in the i
need to stop this video
kids to edgar i pay for your dog food ed
you're making pitch millions of views
oh he's doing the little thumbs up me
that's so cute
meanwhile in an alternate universe
hey we got an among us intro
[Music]
nice i like it all right guys that's
it for this week's wow let me know what
you think about the new microphone is it
good is it better
i'm improving on the quality remember to
subscribe to the channel become a member
it goes to charity this month's charity
is going to be
mental health related i haven't picked
it yet so if you have
any suggestions let me know and that's
it for now
see you next time
[Music]